homes schools and businesses destroyed
from the air the extent of damage in Las
taherias is clear
on the ground it's a Race Against Time
to search for the missing
many people are trapped under layers of
rubble and mud
torrential rain caused the El Pato River
to burst its banks triggering a
landslide
the River overflowed and there are
people we still haven't found that are
trapped we need help my brother is
missing it's not only my pain we're all
feeling it
I haven't slept I haven't eaten I don't
know if my niece is in there or the
water dragged her
Luis Fuentes is standing where his shop
once stood
so many families lost their homes I've
just lost my Pizzeria that opened only
two years ago I'm a new entrepreneur now
look I have nothing
around a thousand emergency Personnel
are taking part in the rescue and search
operation Los taherias is 67 kilometers
Southwest of Venezuela's Capital Caracas
the city's been hit the hardest by this
year's La Nina weather pattern that
brings wetter conditions to Asia Africa
and Latin America
last night's hurricane produced a low
pressure system that quickly caused
flooding that's a hundred liters of
water per square meter which is a record
for rainfall in this area in one month
our shelters are being set up
emergency crew are working to restore
electricity and water supplies president
Nicolas Maduro has described the
situation as difficult and painful
Al Jazeera